johann hedeval says
which one of your interviews made you
feel more energized directly afterward
and perhaps
inspired you to try and apply
well which ones made you more energized
afterward and which ones made you feel
tired
okay virtually every single interview
makes me feel wired right afterward
though i generally go into them
extremely
habitudinous and and lacking of energy
and that's one because of my general
let's say dullness of mind
but two that's because i'm often tired
and fasting
directly before in an effort to study
for the interview it's difficult for me
to get sleep
when i know a podcast is coming up the
next day because i'm thinking about it
thinking about it and i have trouble i
have
i have extreme trouble with my own mind
i'm uncomfortable with my own mind
and it's something i need to work on
it's something i struggle with
it's difficult to shut my mind off and
meditation does not help
has not helped i've tried it many many
times
as for what drained me what interview
drained me there are two interviews that
actually drained me
mithuna's interview on looking glass
universe i was so tired going into it
i was just falling falling taking
everything
from me to just to read and to pay
attention to the word she's saying
a little bit of that is happening right
now that was not because she was
an insipid guest at all it was because
of my own
innervatedness and listlessness as for
the other guest that drained me
thomas campbell okay thomas bless his
heart
he is my friend well he i don't know if
he would consider me a friend i consider
him a friend i hold him with high regard
but that man is incapable of giving an
answer that is less than two minutes
long
in fact often his answers would go up to
30 minutes long
and i'm just thinking time is money here
tom i have 100 questions to get to
and i have a massage to get to and my
wife is coming home
and i would like to eat at some point
and you've told me this before and
you're saying the same sentiment in
different words
50 times can we please get to the point
so thomas was extremely draining
he speaks laboriously and is impossible
for me to get a quick answer out of him
but bless his heart